[Music]  Queen Elizabeth and Megan Markel are  giving us bestie goals the pair looked  thick as thieves in England on Thursday  for a jam-packed day of events together  after spending the night on the same  train for a royal sleepover the two  kicked off their appearances the Queen  looking gold in a lime-green dress and  jacket with a matching hat while the  newly minted duchess of Sussex donned a  chic white Givenchy dress with a black  belt the occasion marked Megan's first  appearance without Prince Harry and a  source tells ET the Queen gifted her a  pair of pearl and diamond earrings for  the moment adding quote Megan was a bit  nervous but took her lead from the Queen  our source says this is considered  Megan's most important engagement yet  and while greeting residents of Chester  the 36 year olds couldn't help but gush  over her new hubby calling him quote the  best husband ever  I could barely let me finish proposing  can I say yes  [Music]